[Musique]
et
bonjour et bienvenue dans ce nouveau
numéro de vip
aujourd'hui nous recevons alex pullin
multi-talents bonjour alors vous êtes
réalisateur acteur humoriste chanteur
vous venez d'une petite commune
yvelinoise comment vous est venue cette
passion un petit peu de larmes
alors ça les premières choses que j'ai
fait c'est prendre le caméscope de mon
père et faire des sketchs avec les
copains donc franchement je sais pas
trop nous ça m'est venue j'étais un
boute en train
je prends tout petit
je pense c'était une manière pour moi
d'exister quoi un petit peu faire de
m'amuser et de rechercher un petit peu
le regard des autres quelques pas et le
chant vous avez commencé avec l âge par
exemple le chant c'est un peu apparu de
venir
autonome vert quand j'ai commencé la
guitare vers j'ai commencé à guitare à
10 ans et je pense peu de temps après 12
13 ans j'ai commencé à chanter parce que
voilà c'était on est forcément on a nos
idoles
groupe de rock à l'époque c'était pas du
rap c'était rock
donc voilà on fait des groupes avec les
potes et va il faut bien quelqu'un qui
se met au chant donc je me met
spontanément au début ce champ de faux
et puis je m'améliore en fumant au fur
et à mesure et vous avez fait quelles
études alors après alors après je fais
troisième satrape donc école
d'audiovisuel
voilà c'était soit ça soit un bts 2
d'informatique et je prie que finalement
j'ai pas été pris au bts informatique
parce que ça me correspondait mieux à
franchement je me suis éclaté à l'école
j'ai découvert ça m'a ouvert les yeux
sur ce qui était là en fait avant
c'était mon plaisir est là vraiment les
professeurs m'ont porté le regarde sur
ok c'est quoi une oeuvre artistique quoi
c c'est pas que du divertissement s'est
montré un point de vue voilà c'est où on
place la caméra justement pour accentuer
le point de vue qu'on a sur le sujet et
c'est donc c'était vraiment passionnant
tombé dedans j'ai fait c'est génial et
puis après on sort des études et puis là
c'est plus compliqué bon c'est plus
terre à terre faut trouver un boulot
donc je commence à être monteur à la tv
et puis bon au début on passait par
assistant monteur c'est des tâches qui
étaient de nuit
pas très pas très marrant pas très
créative document donné j'en ai eu marre
enfin j'ai une énergie et une maladie
des yeux qui s'est déclarée en fait et
du coup ça risquait je risquais d'être
aveugle à plus ou moins long terme
et là ça m'a mis un bon coup de fouet je
me suis dit écoute ton boulot à la télé
là d'assistant menteur ou en fait
j'avais je passais pas monteur j'en
avais marre c'était pas créatif c'était
dans une bulle chaîne people
donc moi j'étais frustré et je me suis
dit allez j'essaie de me lancer dans
l'artistique
donc j'ai arrêté totalement j'ai perdu
mon statut d'intermittent tant que
technicien je les regagner jean un an
après en tant qu'artiste donc beaucoup
de gens se rappellent de vous en tant
que alex et sa guitare
vous avez sorti plusieurs albums et
plusieurs ep in style de musique c'était
bon je dirais de la chanson rock à
textes avec un peu d'humour
ouais qu'est ce que vous voulez faire
passer comme message d'euros musique ça
dépend vraiment ce que j'aimerais bien
dans le format court de la chanson c'est
que ces voix là c'est à chaque fois
c'est un message différent en fait ça à
chaque fois je me nourris de ce qui me
tracasse
et voilà c'est une façon pour moi de
l'exprimer de dormir aussi souvent le
fait de prendre du recul d'en rire etc
ça a toujours été ma façon de
fonctionner je me suis dit toujours
déjà c'était un faux pas que ça se
transforme en thérapie c'est le glissage
parce que sinon les gens faut pas qu'ils
assistent à une thérapie mais en tout
cas quand on a suffisamment de recul
pour pour parler des problèmes g alger
d'eau chaude par les pré commandes de
problèmes ou de sujets assez fort assez
intense c'est lourd mais avec légèreté
avec l'humour et tout ça et c'est donc
voilà c'est les petits tracas que je
peux avoir au cours de ma vie à chaque
fois c'est je le mets dans l'art en fête
et donc vous avez aussi un statut
d'humoriste vous avez fait plusieurs
scènes notamment avec un spectacle
s'appelait amour propre
de quoi il parle et ça ils parlaient de
s'aimer c'est un peu mon sujet récurrent
de s'aimer de s'apprécier comme on est
voilà c'était un peu ça le message de
l'amour propre c'est au début un mec un
peu looser qui qui cherche l'amour et
qui cherche en fait au début du
spectacle je disais bon bah ça y est
j'ai trouvé l'amour pour que les gens se
fassent pas trop de souci pour moi
finalement vous voyez cette quête de
l'amour et à la fin on se rend compte
qu'en fait j'ai trouvé l'amour envers
moi même la personne que j'ai trouvé
c'est moi même voilà s'il y avait une
chanson d'ailleurs où je parlais de la
personne aimée et j'en parlais super mal
et donc les gens ils allaient il ya un
côté voilà c'est vrai aussi be est en
fait je parlé de moi donc finale à sa
sauce et finissaient par ça ça c'était
la chanson je m'aime quoi la boucle
était bouclée puisque je pense vraiment
qu'il faut s'aimer à vendre des milliers
de cadeaux de quoi donc voilà c'est
difficile de réussir à cv ouais travail
d'une vie pas parce que on a un
background quoi c'est ces voix là
forcément moi ça commence au collège les
quolibets les petits surnoms
voilà appui
j'étais là rigolo de service
voilà enfin je pense que c'est lié
l'humour est lié un peu à ça c'est que
n'étant pas n'ayant pas la cote auprès
des de la gente féminine je pense j'ai
développé d'autres armes
j'ai fait de la magie j'ai fait de
l'humour j'ai fait de la guitare j'ai
fait donc le multi talents je pense bien
dollar s'était pas c'était pas conscient
je me suis pas dit bon à leur plan de
bataille comment je vais pouvoir pêcher
autrement non je pense est inconscient
et au final c'est vrai qu'aujourd'hui je
suis plus serein avec tout ça et du coup
j'ai pas forcément besoin d'être drôle
tout le temps j'ai du coup j'aime bien
aussi parler d'autres en fin de sujet
des fois sérieusement avec plus
d'émotion et cetera parce que j'adore
vraiment voilà moi ce qui me plaît dans
les heures c'est ressentir des émotions
que ce soit là rires ou être ému touché
et c'est dans l'une de vos oeuvres où on
a beaucoup d'émotion c'est votre web
série qui est 100 en ce moment là
beaucoup de suspense beaucoup de stress
quel est le sujet de cette série le
sujet le premier sujet qui saute à
l'oeil c'est
c'est la liberté d'expression c'est
c'est je dirais plus la critique des
gens le jugement qu'on se portent les
uns envers les autres et
voilà c'est ça c'est parce que
finalement le de le faire je me suis
rendu compte qu'on était libre
finalement dans ce pays on l'a vu ces
derniers temps
la liberté d'expression est défendue
vraiment corps et âme
mais finalement aujourd'hui ce qui est
difficile c'est que l'information se se
diffuse tellement rapidement que
l'information une blague par exemple
peut se retrouver sous le nez de plein
de gens qui n'avaient pas demandé à
avoir cette blague et eux mêmes de la
même manière et peuvent réagir et la
réaction peut se retrouver à nouveau
sous le nez de tous les gens donc ça
crée une boule de neige qui fait que
avant si elle n'y avait pas d'autant de
des fusions comme ça de réseaux sociaux
etc
donc tu étais au spectacle tu vas une
blague faisait pas tu sortais de la
salle où tu allais dire à tes potes ça
m'a pas plus le mec il a fait ça va et
ça s'arrêtait là la maintenance est papa
suffixe y en a un qui réagissent l'hôte
il est d'accord pour vous et nous on se
retrouve avec cette avalanche de hockey
je voulais faire une blague et encore
souvent moi je fais pas de blague
gratuite comme je voulais dire le truc
c'est c'est toujours de parler d'un
sujet qui me touche
et donc si je fais une blague c'est
rarement gratuit est souvent là on m'a
prêté une mauvaise intention alors qu'en
fait c'était pas du tout le sujet de ma
blague comme avec macron je me moquais
de douala de la langue de bois
les gens pensaient que je me moque à des
sourds avec un autre truc je fais une
blague sur le mât paranoïa de de choper
des maladies parce que j'ai justement
plusieurs fois des petits problèmes de
santé
donc maintenant je suis un peu stressée
dès que j'ai quelque chose et là on m'a
dit vas tu te moque des gens qui sont
mordus coronavirus voilà en fait on nous
prête des fautes d'intention mais les
gens sont un peu à cran et forcément ils
ont des informations qui leur arrive de
toutes parts qui sont pas demandées donc
c'est ça la difficulté aujourd'hui c'est
en tant qu'artiste c'est de se préparer
à recevoir l'otan des compliments que
des gens qui n'apprécient pas parce que
quand les gens paient une place de
spectacle ils savent un peu ce qu'ils se
renseignent sur ce qu'ils viennent voir
quand ils aiment leur écran on leur
propose des trucs donc et après c'est
cette maladie de tout commenté aussi de
tout juger quoi ce qu'il faudrait qu'on
arrive à je trouve à arrêter quoi et
donc du coup cette web série s'est un
peu tous l'objet
de la websérie qui viennent de sortir
qui s'appelle seul qu'on finit donc je
rappelle qu'à onze épisodes de six
minutes
donc vous l'avez un peu dit mais de quoi
ça parle compte apparu au début donc au
début c'est un pitch concret le puits du
concret c'est un humoriste comme par
hasard qui sans même un confinement et
qui du coup décide de faire un concert
en live pour les internautes il fait son
concert c'est une catastrophe le concert
puisque forcément n'y a pas
d'interaction avec le public
c'est pitoyable et à la fin ça finit
fait une chaussure sur le coronel virus
et du coup il ya un internaute qui
réagit super mal en menaçant disent non
c'est pas drôle de machin ça s'enflamme
et il lui dit je vais te crever et donc
après le mec se dit
il va peut-être venir chez moi
s'il trouve où j'habite je suis mal quoi
et c'est ce qui se passe que les mecs se
fait enfermer dans une cave par ce gars
live il se réveille c'est fait prêt
aurait assommé et du cou
et du coup il se réveille et il ya ce
mec-là qui le titille et qui va le
titille un peu de manière étrange plus
en avant cela dans la série et plus
c'est spécial on dirait que le mec le
connaît on dirait que voilà il y fait de
faire des trucs des fois qu'il amène à
se poser des questions sur lui même donc
on se dit mais qu'est ce qu'il veut
finalement ce mec-là quoi ça peut aller
introspection à si c'est ça c'est que
c'est ce que j'étais peut-être dire que
au début c'est un peu le jugement des
autres et ça se transforme un peur
jugement personnel de mal je suis face à
moi-même je suis tout seul
le confinement doit clairement quand
j'étais en confinement
c'est on se retrouve quand même un peu
seul face à soi même et du coup
introspection moi moi en même temps
j'aime bien d'introspection que c'est
pour moi ça fait partie du travail des
artistes et du coup vous avez réalisé
cette série parce que vous étiez seul 11
épisodes 6 minutes vous êtes l'acteur
vous êtes le réalisateur vous êtes
occupé du son des musiques
comment s'en sort benz au sort
le tour si le plus dur c'est le tournage
le reste ça allait mais le tournage bat
donc on pose et on se dit ok mon premier
plan dont déjà j'avais bien décrit tout
le scénario à l'avance j'avais plus ou
moins fait mon découpage c'est à dire
que quels plans vont correspondre au
scénario donc une fois qu'on a ça on dit
ok j'ai je crois que j'avais 250 plants
à tourner donc là en fait voilà
l'impression d'être en bas d'une
montagne et allez on y va on grimpe
grimpe et donc là au début c'est ok je
vais faire un plan faut que je fasse un
gros plan de moi qui fais ci qui fait ça
je pose la caméra et là c'est compliqué
parce qu'à la caméra allé trop loin
heureusement j'avais un moniteur mais
avec le moniteur pour faire le point bon
bah je suis obligé de mettre quelque
chose à ma place
allez faire le point je me remets dans
le cadre ok bon ok c'est bon pour
l'image le micro machin puis après il ya
l'éclairage aussi donc je peux je pose
des éclairages une fois que tout est
prêt je commence à jouer et la pub la
plus grande difficulté c'est je fais le
truc et après je sais pas quoi en penser
enfin il ya personne qui va me dire
c'est bien à bien attention à ce truc là
à là on est seul face à soi même c'est
ok c'est bien ça me plaît pour ce faire
confiance et ça c'est pour moi c'était
le meilleur exercice parce que forcément
tant qu'artiste on doute beaucoup
enfin je reproche pas le pour moi mais
et c'est ça qui est je pense qu'il faut
pas trop douter c'est bien de se
remettre en question mais il ya un juste
milieu à trouver et du coup faut se
faire confiance à un moment donné faut
avancer
faut pas essayer faut pas faire dix
mille prise par exemple moi je me suis
fixé la règle d'essayer de faire trois
prises maxi sauf si vraiment il ya un
truc qui déconne mais à un gros parce
que sinon tu as toujours envie d'en
faire tu dis pas je vais faire mieux je
vais faire mais je veux faire mieux ou
montage la 15 prises et tu fais j'ai
même plus qu avant c était le moyen de
prise et finalement c'est réussi bah
j'espère que je suis content déjà
franchement j'ai revu un pack du recul
ce que j'ai pris un peu de recul sur la
série est juste que je suis fier du
résultat qu'un et donc j'ai vu qu'il y
aurait pas de deux
m e saison quels sont les autres projets
à venir c'est pas vrai si si c'est vrai
que ça se clôt l'histoire se clôt donc à
priori oui pas de pas de deuxième saison
les projets futurs ça sera bas avec une
équipe je l'espère enfin j'ai déjà
tourné en équipe mais là j'ai envie de
partager
l'acte de créer avec d'autres personnes
de m'entourer l'idée c'est de trouver
des producteurs pour forger des projets
dans sous le bras sujet 2 courts
métrages j'ai une série une autre série
mais là un peu différente
j'ai un long métrage aussi et voilà
c'est encore plus ou moins à l'état de
projet chaque chaque chaque jeu projet
j'ai à dire est encore à l'état de
construction mais c'est ce qu'il faut de
toute façon les producteurs arrivent
aime pas qu on arrive avec le produit
fini ils veulent qu'on leur pitch le
projet donc voilà vraiment j'espère y
arriver jusqu'au long métrage où la
série plus longue et de produits voilà
que j'ai encore des choses à dire quoi
bon bah vous viendrez nous en parler
quand ce sera fait
exclusion merci beaucoup à l'expulsion
d'avoir été avec nous on peut retrouver
tous sur toutes vos informations sur
votre site internet www points alex
cudlin point fr et on vous êtes le
meilleur
merci merci à vous et merci à vous
d'avoir suivi cette émission se retrouve
bientôt dans un nouveau bide
[Musique]
mais